what's up guys okay so we are here at
the launch of the all-new samsung s22
and the tab s8 here in singapore courses
that an embargoed event by the time
you're watching this video it is live we
can talk about it so we've been
introduced to the all new phones the
s002 ultra s22 plus and s22 as well as
the tab s8
and uh first impressions we'll talk
about the s22 ultra because this is
gonna be the one that's gonna surprise
most people so first impressions we're
gonna go through every single spec
because you probably watch the keynote
and you can read the website we'll talk
about some of the things that stood out
to us and then of course we'll do some
other videos getting into gaming
photography editing all that great stuff
with a lot of these products so let's
talk about some of the stand-up features
first and foremost the s pen and the s22
plus it's here it's just like the note
series it's been redesigned um
and it is fantastic and i'm actually
kind of glad they did this because it
was always sort of this weird situation
where you had the the galaxy phones that
would come out in the beginning of the
year then the note would come out and
sort of trump the galaxy line and you'd
be like well
what happened to my galaxy s20 or 21
well
it's all now in one phone which does
make a lot of sense this s pen has been
enhanced you get 2.8 milliseconds in
terms of latency that is down seventy
percent from nine milliseconds where it
was previously so this is a big big
difference
and in terms of my usability on it i
mean it's fast it responds really well i
tried a little bit of drawing a little
bit of writing i haven't really gotten
into too much depth with this yet but
there is a noticeable noticeable
difference is it as big as you might be
thinking actually not quite but you do
notice it in the handwriting for me at
least in the most part and i think for a
lot of you out there that are into
drawing procreate if you want to do any
sort of sketching and shading things
like that that sensitivity will
definitely come into play now let's talk
about the size of the phone now the
ultra is the big boy of the family okay
rightfully so but it feels very good in
the hand and the display is not curved
on the sides even though the phone is
curved the display is flat which is very
nice because when you want to use the s
pen you don't want the pen to be falling
off on the edges like it used to do on
the previous note versions samsung of
course has fixed this and they've stayed
to this flatter design on the top screen
which is welcomed the display let's talk
about this amazing amla display got 120
hertz refresh rate or 60 hertz you can
change or it can adapt on its own and it
gets up to 1750 units of brightness
outdoors
inclusive with ai you're going to see
this in bright sunlight i can tell you
right now we're shooting video with this
thing with to turn the brightness all
the way down on this it is super bright
the colors are vibrant it is an awesome
display samsung's always made some of
the best displays on the market and it
is right here in the s22 ultra now in
terms of the process we have the all-new
snapdragon 8th gen one on this now
there's been a lot of benchmarking back
and forth or how good this is versus you
know other options out there on the
market i can tell you just from my
initial hands-on it is lightning quick
it responds very well no lag no issues
opening up apps again we are using
pre-production phones so when we get a
production unit in our hands we'll run
through more of the benchmarks the specs
we'll do gaming editing all that great
stuff for you guys out there but i can
tell you that the snapdragon 8101 is
actually a very impressive chipset and
here in singapore where we used to get
the exynos processor we're actually
getting the snapdragon in our country so
that is a big deal for singapore users
so i'm glad that they uh transitioned to
that let's talk about some of the ai
features inside of this phone samsung's
really building ai into this fourth
nanometer processor the eighth of the
snapdragon 8th gen one and that comes
into photography videography it comes
into the way that you use the s pen and
just battery life and security all those
things come into play and you do notice
it here and there i have to say with the
photography aspect
this is something with the samsung
phones previously i always felt was a
little bit lacking in terms of detail or
i figured wasn't doing so well in low
light that has now changed in this ultra
and also the s22 plus and s22 and
especially with this 108 megapixel
sensor in this it is working very very
well and low light for video looks great
the auto focusing is lightning quick the
transition is got a nice focus rack to
it so it doesn't look like a digital
like
zip zip zip kind of a thing if you're
transitioning from a subject to another
subject it gives it a nice sort of
cinematic look to it and it does resolve
really well at least on this display now
we haven't taken the files off these
phones we can't do that yet but when we
do so i'm excited to see how they look
on a larger display of course when we
put into our final review video but uh
besides that let's talk about the
differences between the ultra and of
course the s22 and s22 plus the ultra's
got the 108 megapixel camera that's the
main camera on this then you have you
have two telephoto lenses as well you
have a laser auto focusing system in
this you can look at the back of this
thing it is absolutely stacked but when
you go into the s22 plus and 22 instead
of 108 you have a 50 megapixel sensor
then of course 12 megapixel 12 megapixel
for your wide and your telephoto so
those are some of the main differences
so if you are a camera person you're a
video person you want the best of the
best you got to spring for the ultra
okay in the samsung world but if you are
okay with just look i take some photos
some video once in a while but i just
want something a little bit smaller
something a little bit more you know
easy to carry around then i would say go
for the s22 plus or s22 depending on
what you want you're still going to get
that same power that's the same
snapdragon processor inside of all these
phones it just varies on the cameras and
which those features that are inside of
them that's pretty much it in the
nutshell thus far what we're going to do
now is we're actually going to take a
look at the all new tab s8 which is very
very impressive it's like a 14 inch
display it looks awesome it looks like a
laptop replacement so zacky and i are
going to take that through his paces and
our first impressions and we'll let you
know what that's like right now here at
geek culture we love our keyboards
especially with the all-new logitech mx
keys mini an elegant and functional
keyboard its ultra responsive rounded
keycaps are super stable and quiet for
more productivity there are buttons to
enable dictation microphone audio
control and emojis the backlit keys
illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or five months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com
alright guys so now we are looking at
the all new tab s8 ultra
14.6 inch display for a tablet how
awesome is that basically a laptop
replacement for a lot of you out there
you want the ultimate ultrabook
basically this is it uh you've got the
attachment to the keyboard you got a
trackpad which is very responsive s pen
storage in the back and that same
latency that we had on the s22 ultra
that 2.8 milliseconds in terms of
latency is on this s pen as well here
but looking at this display this amoled
display 120 hertz refresh rate is
absolutely awesome to see in person
you're not going to notice it here on a
youtube video at all but when you get it
in front of you it looks amazing to see
it and i think for a lot of creators out
there if you're into let's say you can
edit on lumofusion now that's available
here on android you can edit your videos
your photography you want to draw this
is going to be a tablet a lot of you are
going to gravitate towards in the
android ecosystem and i think samsung's
done a tremendous job with this of
course it is dex compatible it can sync
with your phone and your tablet as well
so if you're working on your let's see
your s22 plus ultra or 22 for that
matter you can sync your content over
here to the tablet of course depending
on the app that you're using but i just
love the overall design it is super thin
the bezels are very thin as well i think
it's only six millimeters something like
that it is very thin
and this is a really awesome tablet to
use so i think
i think for our full video review on
this we're going to do some editing on
lumafusion on this because i've used
lumafusion on the ipad but to go on this
with a 14.6 inch display with the s pen
is going to make my life so much easier
because when you do get in edits you
want to you know really go into the
sound files into your waveforms and you
also want to edit your clips and your
transitions you really need to dig deep
but you want a nice large display for
that and that's where this is going to
come in handy you artists out there the
same thing as well
the key travel on this feels really good
really nice key travel to this also
what's new on this tablet is dual front
camera support so you can go more close
up or more wide angle depending if
you're in a conference call you can do
that also mic isolation as well so if
you're in a room full of kids just
screaming and yelling parents you know
what i'm talking about you're working
from home can't get the kids stuff from
you talking too loud there's isolation
on that as well so that is another
attribute that is really cool to this so
anyway those are my thoughts on the
all-new galaxy s 22 s 22 plus and 22
ultra and of course the tab s8 ultra
we're going to be doing a deep dive into
a lot of these products videography
photography gaming
video editing content creation we're
going to be doing with all these
products so do stay uh subscribe to the
channel for those videos that do come
out in the very near future but gotta
say i mean samsung's come out guns of
blazing and sn 2022 and it's going to be
a very exciting year
for the tablet and smartphone categories
so with that guys
new content coming take care stay safe
and we will chat to you soon take care
you